A team of researchers have developed an incredible
new technology that allows them to reprogram
skin cells into any cell an ailing body needs,
with a single touch.
The technology is called Tissue Nanotransfection
(TNT).
It involves using nanochip technology that
could generate any kind of cell within a patient’s
own body.
The new cells could repair injured tissue
or restore function of aging tissue, organs,
blood vessels and even nerve cells.
Here’s how it works a nanotechnology-based
chip about the size of a postage stamp is
placed on the skin and stimulated by an electrical
current.
In less than a second the chip creates nanometer-scale
entry pathways into tissue cells.
Or, basically, provide a way to access skin
cells -- like an opening.
These openings can be used to deliver a cocktail
of reprogramming factors.
This “cocktail” is a combination of genes
that reprogram the cell’s DNA.
Reprogramming the cell basically turns a skin
cell into an induced pluripotent stem cell.
As you probably know stems cells can then
be reprogrammed into any cell the body needs.And
it does all this without hurting the patient,
or having to take the cells out of the body.
Which is how we currently do stem cell therapy.
This technology allows any cell to turn into
a stem cell provided, of course, it’s a
dividing cell.
Skin cells naturally replenish so are a perfect
“fertile land” where the elements of any
new organ can be grown.
In this study, the team was able to reprogram
skin cells to become vascular cells in a mouse’s
leg that was in need of better blood flow.
In two weeks, the leg was saved.
Skin cells reprogrammed into nerve cells were
also able to repair the brains of mice recovering
from strokes!
This technology is still in the research phase.
So far it’s only been tested on mice, but
the team hopes to begin clinical trials soon.
The implications of cell reprogramming are
huge.
Something as simple and easy as this method
could change stem cell therapy forever.
Doctors could just, recruit your own cells
to fix a problem… and it’s not like you’re
short on cells… why not put them to good
use?
Nanotechnology is super cool.
Maybe you think so too?
You could buy nano.news or nano.expert from
Domain dot com!
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Get 20% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
So speaking of the risk of rejection with
new organs, ever wonder why exactly that happens?
Well, we’ve got the answer right here.
What other body mysteries would you like us
to dig into?
Let us know in the comments, be sure to like this video, and subscribe for more Seeker.